the world's most famous escape artist
Harry Houdini he thrilled audiences with
dazzling illusions and death-defying
stunts this mastermind was from here
Budapest Hungary a city obsessed with
escaping and the escaped legacy still
continues thanks to this guy
welcome to Borough Park
[Music]
escape rooms find the clue solve the
riddle crack the code these
team-building puzzles are popping up all
over the planet in fact here in Budapest
there are over 80 of them but back in
2010 escape rooms didn't exist it was
only till this man thought up the idea
I'm eligible Kovich the creator of para
park which is the first real-life escape
room game I was a social worker who
specialized with teamwork his speciality
was playing problem solving computer
games but then I realized it could be
work in a physical environment in the
real world so within three months
Attila had quit his job found a space in
Budapest and opened the world's first
escape room so here in Budapest we have
three rooms one it's a shorter game and
two it's classic
one our game this is crime scene 95 an
escape room works like this you and your
friends are locked in a room for 60
minutes you are then tasked with finding
clues and solving puzzles to unlock the
door and thus escape that room
we use symbols colors shapes magnets you
need to find safes you need to open that
safe somehow here to find the egg we
should put in the net and with that
number you can open that lock with this
glue hopefully you can open the other
door when I showed the players what
would be the solution patent is so easy
to just can do like that you don't need
any special training before a game but
you need work as a team and you need to
share information and this may actually
getting out it can be really simply so
if you ever find yourself in Budapest
and you're stuck inside one of its many
escape rooms like let's say the mob
house or a jail cell
just remember to thank Attila one of the
latest in this city's long tradition of
getting out of hairy situations
[Music]